Dubai often likes to tout that they've
quote unquote escaped oil
according to their official website over
95 percent of their GDP is non-oil based
and less than one percent of their GDP
comes directly from oil this makes it
seem like Dubai is one of the most
advanced and green cities in the world
and when you consider that the UAE has
barely been around for 50 years this
feat just becomes even more impressive
but while I'm sure these GDP statements
are technically true they're also super
misleading in fact these pieces of data
were cherry-picked to make Dubai's
economy look better than it really is
you see it just because oil accounts for
a very small portion of Dubai's GDP does
it not mean that oil has played a small
role in their economy Dubai has a deep
pest with oil and they're still very
much dependent on oil to this day now
this isn't to say that Dubai has
accomplished nothing because they
definitely have they've built one of the
largest and most respected Hospitality
brands in the world they've got Emirates
Airlines the Burj Al Arab the Atlantis
the Burj Khalifa dozens of luxurious
malls and restaurants and who knows what
else they've also made it dramatic
strides when it comes to attracting
westerners and immigrants
the UAE has the world's largest migrant
population in terms of percentage coming
in at 88 percent and that number is
likely weighed down by the rest of the
UAE if we look at Dubai alone the number
is likely higher than 90 percent
on top of this Dubai has some of the
loosest economic policies in the world
they Levy zero income tax on everyday
people and the ruler of Dubai has gone
as far as saying that his country would
never adopt an income tax as a way to
tackle the deficit given their economic
stance it's no wonder why so many high
income earners and wealth individuals
have decided to move to Dubai but with
all of that being said Dubai is nowhere
near as all independent as they would
like you to think so here's the truth
behind the Dubai's oil-free fairy tale
foreign
to really understand why Dubai's
oil-free narrative is misleading we have
to first understand how Dubai became oil
free in the first place
taking a look back the roots of Modern
Dubai date back to the year 1822 at the
time Dubai was a modest fishing village
with a population of only 700 to 800
people the entire area was controlled by
a nearby town that you've probably heard
of Abu Dhabi it was until 1833 that a
tribe called the albu philosopher would
rebel against Abu Dhabi and secede
leading to the independence of Dubai
this movement was led by two men named
Obed bensaid and maktoum binbati and
these two would naturally become the
leaders of the newly formed City opiates
time at the top didn't last too long
though as he would pass away just three
years after the creation of Dubai
this gave control of Dubai to maktoum
who would establish the maktum dynasty
who are the rulers of Dubai did this day
all was not good though Dubai was
constantly fighting for survival both
economically and politically Dubai was
barely making ends meet with her Pearl
diving and fishing and they had no money
left to actually Advance the city to
make things worse Abu Dhabi wasn't
exactly a fan of Dubai secession and
that they were looking to reclaim the
land if possible
it wasn't until 1892 that the UK would
take on the responsibility of Dubai
security enabling Dubai to focus on
economic growth from the very beginning
Dubai was extremely open to capitalistic
ideas one of the first things they did
was establish a completely Freeport in
1901. the port boasted no taxation on
Imports or exports and it also offered
Merchants protection this led to a
massive influx of merchants to the area
who brought along with them at loads of
cargo one of Dubai's biggest Merchants
was a company called The Bombay and
Persia steam navigation Company by 1906
this company alone was trading 70 000
tons of cargo through Dubai this
activity quickly transitioned Dubai into
being a well-known Port within the area
but given Dubai's policy of no taxation
this wasn't all that helpful
economically and things would take a
turn for the worse in 1908 when a
gigantic storm would wipe out a dozen
brilliant boats and a hundred men given
that the majority of these men were
Breadwinners for their families their
death simply pushed Dubai further into
the depths of poverty by this point
Dubai had been independent for nearly a
hundred years but things were worse than
ever at least things couldn't get any
worse than this right well they could
and they would the 1920s would bring
with it a new innovation called cultured
prose which eliminated much of the
demand for pro diving the 1920s also
brought with it the Great Depression
which absolutely ended utterly destroyed
Dubai people started emigrating in
droves and the people who stayed had no
other choice
really the only thing that got Dubai
through this period was the innate urge
for survival
while the state of Dubai was dired to
say the least there was a small glimmer
of hope word was spreading about
neighboring Kingdom striking record
amounts of oil and solving all of their
financial problem having nothing to lose
Dubai would decide to roll the dice with
oil in 1937. but unfortunately this
gamble wouldn't pay off at least not
anytime soon
Lucia around the same time the Americans
would find an oil ocean under Saudi
Arabia and they were busy building
pipelines and oil rigs and trade
Networks not to mention World War II was
just around the corner so trying to find
oil in this tiny little poverty struck
town was no one's top priority but
eventually after World War II came to a
close and all of the hype surrounding
Saudi Arabia died down all companies
would turn their focus to neighboring
areas like Dubai and in 1966 nearly 30
years later oil would finally be
discovered in Dubai but the discovery
was by no means a grand slam the oil was
enough to save Dubai from absolute
Despair and it allowed them to start
building some infrastructure but it was
nowhere near enough to convert them into
a Desert Oasis the same however could
not be said about Abu Dhabi Abu Dhabi
found oil in 1958 and for them it was a
grand slam for perspective the UAE has
nearly 100 billion barrels worth of oil
and at 95 of this is located in good old
Abu Dhabi at first glance it probably
seems like Dubai got super unlucky and
the truth is they did they're literally
located right next to all of the world's
largest oil reserves including Saudi
Arabia Iran Iraq Kuwait Abu Dhabi and
Qatar yet their little city happens to
be one of the few locations where
there's relatively small amounts of oil
while this seems like a curse initially
it actually turned out to be a blessing
because it was exactly what was needed
for the rulers of Abu Dhabi and Dubai to
put aside their differences and to join
forces from Dubai's perspective it would
be stupid to let an eagle battle prevent
them from joining forces with an Emirate
that controls nine percent of the world
well reserves and from Abu dhabi's
perspective they were no longer salted
that Dubai seceded because it looked
like Dubai's pet didn't pay off so it
wasn't too hard for these two Emirates
to join forces with a few smaller
Emirates and create the UAE in 1971. Abu
Dhabi would have become the capital of a
new country and the ruler of Abu Dhabi
Sheikh Zayed bin Sultan al-nayan would
become the first president of the UAE
this probably doesn't and seemed too
Monumental a couple of neighboring
cities got together and the richest of
the bunch became the leaders but this
moment was actually a game changer sure
Dubai did have to make some political
sacrifices but this is when Dubai truly
won it wasn't when they seceded from Abu
Dhabi or when they opened a tax-free
shipping board or when they struck oil
themselves no it was right here because
this marked the beginning of Abu Dhabi
extending significant financial support
to Dubai that's still continuing to this
day
foreign
ever since the creation of the UAE Abu
Dhabi has acted as the Godfather of
Dubai funding dozens of projects handing
out several loans and bailing them out
on numerous occasions one of the first
projects that Dubai embarked on after
teaming up with Abu Dhabi was building a
new Port called the port of jabel Ali
this port was built throughout the late
1970s and it would be opened in February
of 1979. since then this port has become
home to 5 000 different companies from
120 different countries and the port of
jabel Ali currently ranks as the 11th
busiest port in the world but as you
might remember this wasn't Dubai's first
shot at the building a port in fact they
tried building a tax report way back in
1901 that however was wiped out by a
single storm while the port of jabel Ali
has survived numerous explosions attacks
and natural disasters the key difference
between the two is that one was backed
by oil money while the other was not
anyway shortly after the support was
completed Dubai set out on her biggest
and most successful project of all time
Emirates Airlines Emirates was
personally funded by the royal family of
Dubai in 1985 and Essence turned into
one of the most luxurious and respected
airlines in the world but while people
view Emirates as being rich with their
jumbo a380s Emirates actually makes less
money than Delta American Airlines
Lufthansa United and even Southwest so
Emirates is much more of an image piece
than a true profit driver and how was
this image piece funded well I think you
know the answer moving on we have all of
a Dubai's vanity projects first they had
the Burj all Arab in 1999 then they had
the Palm Islands in 2004. after that it
was Atlantis in 2008 followed up by the
Burj Khalifa in 2010 and now we have the
quick Tower though that may be canceled
as the reports Airlines and vacation
destinations grew in popularity these
sectors of the economy simply a how to
paste the relatively small oil industry
and this is why Dubai is able to claim
that oil only makes up one percent of
their GDP but guess who comes to their
rescue whenever they need help well it's
of course their average Partners Abu
Dhabi a perfect example of this is 2008
during the great financial recession as
the global economy cooled down it's hard
to travel and the revenue that Dubai
pulled in they were no longer able to
keep up with vanity projects like the
Burj Khalifa but luckily for them Abu
Dhabi would come to the rescue with the
10 billion dollar bailout we should also
mention that Dubai has yet to pay back
Abu Dhabi not that Abu Dhabi
particularly cares Dubai has
consistently just been rolling over the
dead ever since the financial crisis and
the currently or Abu Dhabi 20 billion
dollars and that's just their debt to
Abu Dhabi Dubai also has loads of
internal and international debt Moody's
and the s p estimate that Dubai total
debt load stands at 79 in dollars
clearly regardless of whether Dubai is
oil dependent or not there's no question
that they're debt dependent
in the end while Dubai likes to convince
the world is that they're completely
self-sufficient and that they've been
able to beat their oil dependents this
is simply not the case even though oil
does not account for a large portion of
their GDP it's literally the only reason
the country was able to develop in the
first place and it's the only reason
that they remain solvent today if it
wasn't for Abu dhabi's oil bailout Dubai
would have likely went to bankrupt back
in 2009 and it's not clear if the Burj
Khalifa would have even been opened this
is probably why they decided to name the
building after the ruler of Dubai at the
time at Khalifa bin zayeda on ION the
truth is that Dubai isn't very much
dependent on Abu dhabi's money backing
and influence on the world stage and
according to device logic Mecca is oil
independent as well after all Mecca is
the world's second and most lucrative
tourist destination in the world only
Beat Now by Dubai and they don't make
much money from oil themselves let's
just forget about the fact that Saudi
Arabia backs Mecca with billions of oil
dollars every year all that matters is
GDP right obviously that reasoning does
not hold up for Mecca and it's no
different but Dubai do you think that
Dubai is oil independent comment that
down below also drop a like if this
video changed your perspective on Dubai
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community suggested video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
foreign